put your name
i will say it once more just to make
sure good afternoon everyone i'm dr
albert burle i'm chairman and ceo
of pfizer and i want to welcome you all
to pfizer's facility here
in poors in particular i want to welcome
marshall of underlying
the european commission president and
her team
madam president it is a great great
pleasure
and honor to have you visit the 3 000
pfizer colleagues who have quite
literally made
miracles happen here over the past year
a warm welcome also to alexander the
crew
the belgian prime minister and his team
as you know pfizer has a long standing
presence
and relationship with belgium and we are
very proud
of our four belgium sites
all of which play an important role in
bringing and innovative
medicines to patients across the world
i also want to welcome biontech's
co-founder
dr oslin touretti oslem as i have told
you so many times and your husband
pfizer could not have asked for a better
partner
than biontech thank you for being here
today and thank you for being here with
us
so all these months
like our guests i'm humbled by what i
have seen here today
our colleagues here are dedicated to the
high quality manufacturing of
an extensive portfolio of innovative
biopharmaceutical products
including our pneumococcal conjugate
vaccine and the number of
important sterile injectable medicines
over the past year of course pfizer
poors
also has become the heart of our covet
19 response
efforts here in europe but also globally
colleagues here have been worked
tirelessly
to ensure we do two things we continue
providing the world with the
life-changing
and life-saving medicines patients rely
on
including medicines desperately needed
by hospitals that have been overwhelmed
by multiple surges of covenant in
pandemic
and of course manufacture and supply the
first
covet 19 vaccine approved by the
european commission
and many other regulatory agencies in
the world but we developed
in partnership with bionicle
the team here has excelled in making the
impossible
possible they have overseen upscaling
efforts
and made continuous improvements to the
sophisticated sterile process
but have ensured pfizer has been able to
deliver
millions of vaccines to senders across
the european union
and worldwide since the start of our
efforts
we have added high speed packing lines
here at purse improved our processes
to double batch size to increase
yield and we deployed more efficient lab
tests
methods to reduce releases time all of
these
efforts have allowed us to reduce our
timelines
from approximately 110 days from start
to vial ready and we are now approaching
an average of
60 days and almost 50 improvement
as you know we have an agreement with
the european commission to deliver 600
million doses by the end of 2021
and of as of today i'm very proud to say
that we have shipped more than
100 million doses to the eu meeting
all our supply commitments to the
european commission
in addition we are really on track to
exceed the established commitments
and we will deliver 250 million doses by
the end of the second quarter
a four-fold increase four-fold repeat
increase
on the first quarters a great quantity
and by may we plan to produce
more than 100 million doses a month in
this manufacturing site alone
with significant and continued
improvements to follow in the coming
months
moving forward tours remains essential
to our plans to supply the world
with approximately 2.5 billion doses
in 2021 and potentially more
in 2022 thanks to the efforts here
in poors and across our extensive
manufacturing network
we stand ready to support the european
union and the world
in this continued fight against covet
19.
madam president mr prime minister
i hope you have enjoyed the opportunity
to meet the team here
in pearce to see firsthand what we have
achieved and to appreciate
the monumental journey we are on a
journey we hope will
underscore our company purpose
which is breakthroughs that change
patients
lives so madam president i will now
invite you to make also a few remarks
thank you so much
uh dr boladia albert thank you very much
for the hospitality indeed it was an
impressive tour through the
manufacturing side
so thanks very much for that prime
minister
the alexander dear islam director
we are meeting here today at a place
which symbolizes three true
european stories first indeed
the european vaccination campaign that
is
picking up speed right now second
europe is leading worldwide on
revolutionary
life-saving mrna and
third in the midst of an unprecedented
health crisis
europe is the global vaccine champion
making vaccines available to the rest of
the world let me start
with a vaccination campaign this week
we pass the mark of 150 million
doses delivered in terms of deployment
we are already we have already passed
123 million
vaccinations and with this
the european union is among the top
three in terms of covet 19 vaccinations
worldwide
after the united states and china
so in other words the eu vaccination
campaign is
on track yes we have had difficulties at
the very beginning
delays and production bottlenecks but we
were able to
counter them due to our broad vaccine
portfolio
and also thanks to strong
and reliable suppliers like biontech
pfizer
indeed the main vaccine used so far in
the european union
is the one produced right here in poors
in belgium a true vaccine powerhouse
and with the enormous efforts of
bioentech pfizer and the acceleration of
their vaccine deliveries
i'm now confident that we will have
sufficient doses to vaccinate 70 percent
of the adult population in the european
union
already in july
and this pioneering technology
we see here will help us with that
this leads me to the second success
story this manufacturing site
was the first to produce an mrna vaccine
at large scale in europe
i saw the lipid nanoparticular skin
earlier that was impressive
to see that when we were visiting the
site
and i was told that this is a machine
that plays the crucial role in the
production of mrna vaccines
the first one ever was built right here
in pers
in that lab last summer a
ground-breaking innovation and this
pioneering technology could be the
backbone
of our future vaccine portfolio
indeed mrna vaccines will be the central
will be central to the eu's preparedness
plan
for fighting covet 19 and other viruses
we are working with biontech pfizer on a
new contract
this contract will foresee the delivery
of
1.8 billion doses
for the years 21 and
223 we will conclude
in the next days it will secure the
doses necessary
to give booster shots to increase our
immunity against the virus
it will provide vaccines adapted
to escape variants that no longer
respond
to the vaccines and it should enable us
to vaccinate if necessary and safe
children
and teenager and it will consolidate
europe's leadership
in mrna technologies
the story of covet 19 vaccines
is that of ground breaking signs
of pioneering spirit dear islam
and ur shaheen and the
miracle of manufacturing albert bola and
your crew
and an incredibly enabling environment
of the host country so alexander without
that it wouldn't be possible
this vaccine has been developed in less
than one year it was unheard of
it seemed impossible only a few years
ago
never before have we seen so many
successful vaccine candidates that were
actually approved
around the world and never before
have we seen such manufacturing
scale up and such cooperation
across the industry across countries
across the globe in just one year
this manufacturing site is producing one
billion doses
in this respect i have good news
our european medicines agency has just
approved
the increase of this site's production
capacity by a further 20 percent
this will make it one of the biggest
vaccine fill and finish
sites in europe i would like
to thank the workers of this
manufacturing site for their
extraordinary
efforts we were witnessing when they
were telling us about it
for working around the clock since many
many months
to produce vaccines for europe and for
the rest of the world
this brings me to my third and last
point this
place is also a symbol for the european
union's
fairness and openness europe is
producing vaccines for europeans
and for citizens around the world we
have exported
more than 155 million doses of vaccine
to over 87 countries worldwide
since december to be clear
we have exported as much as we have
delivered to eu citizens
we are the pharmacy of the world and we
europeans take pride in this
and we invite others to join because we
all know
nobody will be safe until everybody is
safe
thank you so much madam president and i
would like now to invite the prime
minister and the crew
to also make some comments prime
minister yes thank you mr uh
mr bullet thank you madam president and
um
i have to say it's for me a tremendous
honor to be on the same stage with uh
mr richie um you've played
an incredible role in um in the
development of what is being done uh
being done here and um i really would
like to
to um to thank you in the name of all
belgians for a tremendous work that you
and your husband and your team because
no one is doing something on its own
today have done for uh for global
global public health which is a topic
which is really close to my uh to my
heart
um of course thanking all the uh the
staff of
pfizer here in in peers i think we've
seen here
a lot of pride on this on this side and
and rightfully so because what has been
achieved here
especially the ramp up from something
which
a year ago we were barely even talking
about and today
producing it at hundreds of millions at
the same time
it is something that rightfully so the
thousands of people who work here
can have a lot of of pride on and i
really
think that the development of this
vaccine was uh was astonishing
the scaling up really is of biblical
proportions
knowing that a year ago we were not even
we were just making drawings of what we
would be
and we will be doing um even in
netherlands
[Music]
um sites like this really are the
the backbone of how we how we fight this
pandemic
um because of what you're producing here
but also
the dependability and the preventability
of what you are of what you are doing
here
if you want to vaccinate millions of
people this is quite some planning
and if in your planning you can work
with partners who respect the timings
it really means a lot to us but it also
means a lot to the
uh to the population as mrs wonderland
you've
you've called it a vaccine powerhouse
belgium i think that is the case we we
have an
uh quite exceptional position in in in
healthcare
with research research activity with
medical trials activity
and with also a great deal of production
activity and i think it's quite unique
to have the
full spectrum um taking place in in such
a small uh
small small geography would like to
thank you mr burlap for the
the confidence you have had over the
last decades that pfizer has had in
in in belgium and the continued
investments that have taken uh taking
place here i continued investments
um which means a lot the pharmaceutical
industry in belgium is 40 000 people
working in it it's a yearly investment
of three and a half
billion every year it's 40 billion
of exports every year and this year it's
going to be
quite a lot more because of of the
vaccine
vaccine production and this is a result
of choices that have been made over the
last
decades which are linked to the
knowledge we have for example in
in tropical diseases but also some
deliberate political choices
which have been them which have been
made but also and i would like to to
emphasize that
the belief in global cooperation if you
look at what is being produced here the
suppliers
of this vaccine come from more than 80
different countries
it can only work if we respect global
trade it can only work
if we understand that we need to work
together in this and this has always
been our philosophy
that we want to play this role in an
open market
and in a market where everyone is
respecting the uh
the rules above all i think it is um
it's it's teamwork and it's it's
teamwork
in what you are doing here during the
day and doing the multiple nights
because you've mentioned
uh your team has mentioned that it's
also been teamwork
between the private sector and the
public sector and i hope this is one of
the things we will get out of this
crisis
is that when everyone brings at the
table what they're best at
from academia from the private sector
and from the public sector
we can do amazing things and what we
have done over the last year
really is amazing we will look back at
this and i hope
that this is a method we will continue
uh working when i talk about teamwork
um specifically would like to thank your
leadership ursula
in bringing all the european countries
together
and in making this a collective effort
and
there was no other way for us to do it
in a collective effort
and i'm convinced that in the long run
the collective effort will pay off much
more than competitive effort that we see
in some other parts
of the world um teamwork also on the
on the belgian side our vaccination
campaign we've reached two days ago
70 of the plus 65
population which has been vaccinated
this means a huge relief i know people
in my environment my parents for example
i've seen on their face the change
of waiting for the vaccine and having
received the vaccine
it makes a tremendous difference of the
way people look at
at the world and i'm convinced that in
the next months the rest of the
population will have
that gratifying feeling um as well
um last element i hope this is um
this is the start of an uh an increased
confidence of the european project
because i think we've shown here
what we can do but we've also seen what
the potential weaknesses could be
and like with everything i think this is
a moment where um
we need to look at what we can do better
but we also
do not need to be hesitant to point out
what we have done well
and use these methods much uh much more
so again thank you
to you for inviting us uh here i know
your priority is producing and i know a
visit like this is not an easy one to
organize
and thank everyone in pfizer for the
tremendous role they've played
over the last months oh thank you prime
minister it is
not only an honor but a pleasure to have
you and madam president here and
now i would like to invite our very
valued partner and very dear friend
uh dr touretti osler please save your
words
yes first of all thank you very much
for albert for for your kind words
um it's a pleasure for us to be your
partner and it's it's also
a pleasure that i could be here today
and to meet
the highly committed team of comrade
heroes who are working in peers
together with our team to make the
impossible possible
i also would like to to thank
you madam president for this opportunity
to make finally uh your your personal
uh acquaintance and i'm also very happy
to meet
you mr prime minister here at this
occasion
um and also certainly hello to all of
you
at biontech we have been working on mrna
technology for two decades and the
mission
was to develop medicines
against cancer and other serious
diseases
and in january 2020
trusting into the long-standing
research of mrna into our
experience and command of a technology
and in our deep normal knowledge of the
immune system
we decided to embark into the
development of a covet 19 vaccine
and we did this because we trusted we
would be able
to solve the problems in real time and
at that time as you know it was an
unknown territory and an unpredictable
outcome
back then we had treated a few hundreds
of cancer
patients with mrna we were able with our
manufacturing process and our
manufacturing capacities to produce
a few thousands of doses per year
if we now look at where we are today we
are in purse
i have met a team of highly committed
people who are working on manufacturing
of of our kovit 19 vaccine who
proudly presented that they are able to
produce
more than a a billion doses per year
so it's a great and gigantic
achievement to which we we were capable
what we also have learned in these two
years
are two basically two lessons
one lesson is that partnerships are very
important
they have enabled us to stem
the pandemic we have learned that
partnering up in particular not only
with
partners such albert and his team with
with complementary capabilities but with
identical culture and fit is an
important step to make
we have also learned that public-private
partnerships
and for this i would like to thank madam
president
that public private partnerships are
very important
and i can tell you when we founded our
company
many years ago we had a dream and
the dream was not only to develop
paradigm shifting medicines it was also
to
contribute to the formation of
public-private partnerships
of new models which would enable
companies
to better provide for the greater good
and here we have such an example
another lesson we have learned is that
science can make a difference
science and technology that
we can succeed in turning science and
and technology and in survival
and health and we will continue to to do
so
as a while peers and
our other facilities in our network
will continue to supply globally
in parallel we will work on facing and
addressing
our challenges ahead boosting
the third dose addressing variance also
here
science will accompany us with this
i would like to remind us all of our
common motto
world against virus and again thank all
of you
for being here thank you so much uh
and i would like now to to invite
questions if you would like to
raise your hand and our colleagues will
invite you to
the microphone
you